hi everyone
and welcome to google cloud next on-air
today we're going to be talking about
some best practices
for monitoring user experience and for
using custom metric telemetry uh to do
so
on google cloud using cloud monitoring
my name is yuri grinstein
i'm a site reliability engineer here at
google cloud i'm part of the customer
reliability engineering team
i have the good fortune and pleasure of
being joined by mike debrassenii from
niantic
uh mike thank you so much for being here
thank you
and so today we're gonna uh kind of
cover three main areas uh first
i'm really excited to talk to mike about
uh the experience
that he's had actually
putting this stuff into real life
putting the stuff into production so
we're going to talk about
kind of you know what they've done to
monitor user experience
you know focus on service health and how
they've really implemented
some of that stuff from there we're
going to get into how you might actually
start
moving on this journey yourself by first
creating some basic availability
and latency slos using google cloud
monitoring and
from there i'm going to dive into some
best practices for implementing
custom service level indicators using
custom metric telemetry
uh so with that said let's get into it
uh first
you know mike thank you so much for
being here would you mind starting by
telling us a little bit about niantic
architecture and scale and
your role there absolutely so i am
a site reliability engineer with niantic
i'm actually the first dedicated sre and
have been with the company for about
three years
when pokemon go launched i wasn't with
niantic yet but i wasn't definitely an
avid player
i was fascinated by some of the growth
and scaling challenges that launched and
decided
this is awesome i want to be part of
this
so after i joined niantic i helped
launch some of the social features
including the friends
and trading features for pokemon the
ability to send gifts and also the
weather features that
help with the spawn rates and so on for
pokemon
i'm currently the lead sre on the harry
potter wizards unite title
and support several back-end services
and monitoring that are used by current
and future titles
our games are enjoyed by millions of
players worldwide
i'm going to be a little bit vague about
scale but i will say that we do
have a large number of players we have
players that want to play the game 24x7
they want the game to work
whenever and wherever they decide to
play we run on the google cloud platform
and make heavy use of the kubernetes
engine spanner data flow cloud load
balancer and several other gcp services
our architecture is somewhere between
monolithic and a microservice model
we have games that consist of several
discrete components
including the front-end server and
several back-end services to support
the games so the front-end servers take
care of things like keeping track of the
game state player activity keeping track
of game rules
the back-end services take care of
things such as supporting our spatial
database
uh player account registry and then some
of the social features
again the gifting and friends list
all right thank you um so one of the
things you just mentioned were services
so
tell me about how do you monitor the
health of these services
when i started we were using a
traditional monitoring approach so
a combination of prometheus and google
cloud monitoring we actually like the
way that the two work together quite
nicely
and so we support both the
traditional monitoring approach means
that you pick a set of metrics that you
think represent
how well the system is working so that's
this will be a mix of
system metrics like memory and cpu use
and then
game level metrics that might be things
like how many pokemon are being captured
how many spells are being cast how many
players are logged in
you then set thresholds for normal and
then watch for things that indicate
something unusual is going on
so maybe we see that the number of
players has dropped off or the number of
successful pokemon copters that suddenly
dropped off
and this works fairly well there are
some limitations to this approach so
number one it tells you how the servers
are doing but it doesn't necessarily
tell you how the players are doing
there's some guesswork involved in
picking the correct metrics
and figuring out which metrics matter
also picking appropriate thresholds so
that you end up with alerts that are
sensitive but not
so sensitive that they're to the point
of being noisy
it's very very easy to focus on wrong
metrics and it's very easy to miss
problems that may involve a combination
of metrics that
combine in ways you never anticipated
one of the things that we've learned
is that distributed systems tend to fail
in very complex ways
with wizards unite we piloted a slo
monitoring approach with the help of our
partners at google
to complement our traditional monitoring
so
the approach here is to look at the game
from the point of view of players rather
than the servers
so we measure things like request
latency the success rate for requests
from players
both overall and then or a more detailed
level such as the individual actions
that
they may perform in the game we then set
performance targets for these
metrics and end up with service level
objectives or slos
we can then also track error budgets
based on how well we
stick with these slos and how well we
comply over the long term
we then alert based on slo violations or
if we start burning error budget
excessively
okay makes sense uh so it sounds like
some of the primary reasons you're
adopted so to really focus on
you know user experience and kind of how
how the users are perceiving the game
um was that the primary motivation and
then you know what other benefits did
you see from for making this change
so there are a couple of benefits so uh
yeah as we realize
players are not really interested with
the details of our server they do care
if the game is working though
so we should measure that so
what we found is that by implementing a
couple of very simple
slos in the based off of the metrics
from our load balancer latency and
success rate
we were able to tell a lot about the
player experience
they also keep us very honest because
we're not depending on the servers to
report their own metrics
one of the things obviously is that if
the server crashes it's not going to
report anything that says it's in
trouble
something else has to do that so the
effect of this is that problems have
nowhere to hide
if there's something going on whether
it's something internal within the
server or something with our network
infrastructure
we're going to see it as an slo
violation if it affects the players
and then we'll receive an alert so some
of the benefits
we tend to see better quality alerts
we have much less alert noise with our
slo violation alerts
we do know that when we get an alert we
know that there's something going on
that we need to address
the alert doesn't necessarily tell us
what the problem is but it does let us
know that we need to start
our troubleshooting process and this is
where we may look at some of our
existing traditional monitoring
it's also actually taught us a couple of
things about
our deployments that we've done and some
of the regressions that may come up
afterwards
so we found that by watching outside of
the servers
we can now see the effect of doing even
things like a deployment
or planned maintenance this means that
we've actually changed the way that we
do some of our deployments based on some
of the
observed disruption that we were causing
the other thing that we've noticed is
that we can watch for what's called a
slow burn alert
where we're very slowly consuming error
budget but
faster than we should be this would be
such something like a slow leak and a
car tire where
you may not notice that there's a
problem from day to day but you will
definitely notice when you have a flat
tire
so what this is it's watching the
cumulative effect of
small slo violations that may start
after we've made some
change this would be lost in the noise
of a traditional monitoring approach
but with our slo monitoring and our
error budget tracking
they're now very visible and now we know
again that we need to start looking for
a regression
so this sounds great now you have a
better sense of user experience um your
alerts are
of higher quality you know when you get
alert you actually know that there's a
problem
you can also catch problems like the
slow burn situation that you described
so this all sounds great
what's been the hardest part about
making this transition and making this
change
i think selling the idea internally was
actually one of the harder things
a lot of people understand what
traditional monitoring is but
they don't understand necessarily why we
also want to do slo monitoring why isn't
traditional monitoring good enough
so i had to explain that this is a
complement to traditional monitoring
we're not replacing
our existing monitoring we're just
adding to it we're doing something that
means that we're looking at the same
metric data but in a different way and
interpreting it differently
one of the benefits that we realized is
again detecting problems
that we didn't even see coming
the other obstacle that i ran into is
the conception that slos are just for
sres
and nobody else needs to pay any
attention and
actually this is not the case we
definitely need
and want input from product and the rest
of the business
as sres we're very good at measuring
things
product is very good at knowing what we
need to be measuring
and what we need to be looking for
unfortunately the product team is also
very busy and
unless they understand their role in
coming up with good slos
it's hard to get their time so the
approach we took was to
make this as easy as possible by
focusing on one or two starter slos
where we had a pretty good idea and just
needed confirmation from product
once we had that and could demonstrate
some value we were then able to bring in
product and work on some more advanced
slos
yeah so selling this internally is a
challenge getting product to buy into is
a challenge that
that certainly makes a lot of sense i
totally get that
you know looking back on your journey
would you have done anything differently
or you know what would you do
differently
so one of the things that i would have
done is to start simple
uh demonstrate value quickly and focus
on the quick ones
before taking on some of the more
advanced use cases
so as an example one of the things we
tried to do was set up
slos based off of the custom metrics in
prometheus
uh this involves setting up a sidecar
which ingests metrics into stackdriver
we had some concerns about the
cardinality of that metric
or the metrics that we were using and
wanted to pre-summarize the data before
sending it in to the cloud monitoring
service
we found that that was actually at the
time fairly difficult because
there were the the sidecar was in a
fairly
early development state compared to
where it is now
so we ended up working with the
development team behind the sidecar and
we're eventually able to add the feature
that supports
aggregated metrics coming in this was a
huge help for us it let us do what we
want
and the sidecar is now in a much better
state however it did take a long time to
get something
looking back i would have just started
with the load balancer metrics they
actually
gave us something useful very quickly in
about an afternoon's work
and that gave us about 90 percent of
what we were looking for they were also
much much simpler to set up
i can understand that just using the
out-of-the-box little bouncer metrics
rather than kind of building your own
with prometheus and then also
maintaining that additional sidecut
infrastructure
yeah would certainly make things a lot
easier so that's an excellent lesson to
pass on to
folks that are looking to start their
you know their journey down this path as
well
um other than other than that you know
what else would you advise someone who's
looking to kind of you know
follow your footsteps and reproduce this
so
i would say don't be afraid this is
actually not that hard to set up
it's it like i said with the load
balancer metrics we had something in an
afternoon it was very
straightforward the other thing i would
say is that if you can measure it you
can turn it into an slo
so think about the existing metrics that
you already have and see
if there are ways that you can turn them
into an slo that describes user
experience
obviously there are some that will work
very well in our case the load balancer
metrics were
very helpful they were free they were
available out of the box
don't forget also to start simple and go
with the quick and easy win
before taking on the more advanced
challenges that may need some buy-in
from others finally
pick the right tools pick a tool that's
flexible
and that works well with your existing
environment in our case
we chose the cloud monitoring slo api
from google
this supports creating many types of
slos works on all cloud platforms
and supports containerized and virtual
machine environments we're very happy
with how it's worked out for us
all right thank you very much i
appreciate that and again thanks for
being here i think this is
you know some super useful lessons that
i think you have learned that i'm very
happy that you're able to uh you know
pass on to others so
uh thank you very much again from here
what i'd love to do is to walk through
some practical examples of how folks
that are watching this session
can take some of the lessons that mike
has learned and apply them to your own
environment
first i want to show you how to you know
do exactly what mike is saying is how do
you
create some of those basic availability
and latency slos
using some of the out of the box
features in google cloud monitoring
they're there for you to use without
really the need to do any additional
application instrumentation
the way that this works is that you
essentially have to start by
kind of defining your service right the
basic premise here is that you have a
service
and you can be measuring service health
using service level objectives for that
service
uh there are two primary ways by which
you can define the service using the ui
right if your service is running on
google kubernetes engine
or your gke the ui will actually let you
pick one of the gke primitives to
essentially create this logical uh
construct that you can use as a service
so you can use things like gke services
gke deployments even something like a gk
name space and tie your service
definition to that
if your gke cluster has istio installed
on it which is an open source
open source service mesh that allows you
to do things like traffic routing
security encryption
and telemetry or observability
then the services running within the seo
service mesh will also be exposed for
you here
and you can simply pick one of those so
that's the first step right is
on either select the service that's
already been defined uh or define it
yourself
if you're not running on gke if you
actually want to define just just a
custom service
there's an api available that you can
use to do that as well
so that's the first step is select the
service or define the service
the next step would be to pick the sli
sli stands for service level indicator
and this is the metric that you're
actually going to use to essentially
determine
you know at any given point is your
service healthy or not right this is the
thing
that you're measuring that you can be
using as a proxy for
uh user happiness right are my users
happier than that
uh so for specifically for istio
services
uh the slo monitoring scheme will
actually allow you to pick availability
or
latency uh right there because it's
aware that
it's aware of you know what an istio
service is it knows the
istio metrics that are used to expose
things like availability and latency
and you just you just pick the kind that
you want to use uh
if you're if this is not a nifty service
you can actually select
other and essentially pick any metric
within
google cloud monitoring to be used to be
used as
the sli or service level indicator for
that particular service
and then the last step is to actually
define the service level objective
right so you may recall that the service
level
indicator is the metric that we're going
to use to measure service health
the service level objective is the
target that we're going to put that will
actually tell us
you know whether our service is healthy
enough right so that's the last step of
the process
is you pick your set your slo you
determine you know what is the level of
reliability of this
particular service needs to deliver you
specify the time window over which
you're going to measure it
you have the option of using a calendar
window or a rolling window and
the length of that window it's not going
to show you what is your slo compliance
uh looking like right now based on the
metric that you've chosen your
your window and your threshold you
figure out if that's what you
uh if that's the right target for you
and then you just
save the service and you're good to go
so defining an
slo for a service that you either create
or define yourself
uh kind of the for metrics that are
already there for you out of the box
is fairly straightforward uh in this
last part of the presentation
i want to talk about you know what do
you do when the metrics that you want
isn't there how can you go about
adding custom metrics to google cloud
monitoring
in order to use them as service level
indicators
i'm going to discuss you know four major
options right so again these are metrics
that aren't there for you out of the box
so using load balancer metrics that you
might have already talked about would be
a great place to start
that's an option for you i'm going to
talk about specifically
cases where the metrics just don't exist
what can you do so i'm going to discuss
four options
log base metrics uh using the monitoring
api directly
using a custom instrumentation library
like open census or open telemetry
or using prometheus which is a
well-known open source time series
monitoring toolkit
and as i go down this list i'm going to
talk about kind of the basics of each
one
how you might go about implementing it
and then talk about some pros and cons
of each so you can kind of understand
what are the trade-offs of all these
different approaches
so let's start by talking about log base
metrics right fundamentally log base
metrics are the idea that you can take
numerical values in your logs payloads
and convert them into metrics out of the
box we ship
uh metrics that are called system
logging metrics right uh so these are
things that measure for example
log volume ingestions and other things
that you can understand you know how
much logging is happening within your
project
uh you know and really how much that's
going to cost you
you can then define two different uh
metric
measure types based on your application
or system logs
counter metrics would be just things
that kind of tell you how many times
do you see entries that match the
particular filter
right distribution metrics are primarily
what you would use for slis because
you can actually use them to extract um
using a regular expression numerical
values from the logs payload
right so this will be useful for things
like before tracking things like latency
so if you don't have a latency sli and
maybe that latency is being written in
the log somewhere
you can use uh a distribution metrics to
do that
whereas if you want to do an
availability sli where you're just
counting
you know how many errors for example
take place versus number of total
requests
then you can use a counter measure you
know the big obviously the big trade off
of using log base metrics is that
this data has to exist in logs right so
you have to have logs and you know
you're going to be paying for those as
well
uh and this if you already have this
information in your logs
this could be a great place to start
right you should know that if you're
if you're excluding logs right to save
on cost or save on storage
you can't configure log base metrics on
logs that are being excluded
one other thing you should know is if
you want to use
slo specifically for alerting because
there can be a delay between
when logs arrive in a system and when
those values
are essentially aggregated for the
purposes of log based metrics
you know if you want to have very
precise alerting this option may not
actually be
uh you know it means the data latency
may not be sufficiently low for that
purpose
right so when thinking about log base
metrics right the big
kind of advantage of this approach is
that it really doesn't require you to do
any additional instrumentation if logs
are already there you can just use the
data
you know the big trade-off is going to
be things like the latency but also you
need to have the logs there and this
could
result in additional charges for you
uh your second option for custom metric
telemetry instrumentation may be
actually using
the monitoring api to create the metrics
directly within
the monitoring backend so the way they
would you would do that and i'm going to
walk you through some
base a basic example of how you would do
that specifically using a node.js
so first you set up the configuration
right this is where you kind of set up
you know what is the metric that you
want to write
uh its type it's uh
how you'd actually retrieve it and
things like that right the next step is
you create what's called the metric
descriptor
so this is uh just kind of it tells um
it provides the api a way to determine
whether the values are going to be
written
then you create a data point object
right your data point is going to
have an interval that describes when
this information is being written
and then it's going to have the value of
like what are the what's the number
what's the
time series value you're actually
writing
from there you use the metric descriptor
to create a time
series so remember in google cloud
monitoring you can have
multiple time series against a specific
metric descriptor
so this is where you create the
particular time series and finally you
actually make a call to write your data
point value
against that particular time series so
as you just saw
this there's a lot of steps involved if
you want to use the api
directly right the big advantage of
using the monitoring api directly is
because you're interacting at the lowest
possible layer here you have all the
control you need so you have you know
full control over
exactly how the metric descriptor gets
created how the time series
are created how the data points are
written right so if you need that level
of granular control
using the monitoring apis is a great way
to accomplish that
as you saw the big tradeoff here is
complexity right you have to manage all
of these different things
so you know there's probably a better
way to do that right and
what we you know recommend if you
actually want to do this kind of
instrumentation
is to use these custom instrumentation
libraries so you should be aware that
in the past we've recommended open
census which is this open source
metric and trace instrumentation library
that actually came out of the the census
library here at google
uh recently there's been an announcement
that open census
is actually merging with the open
tracing project in a new project called
open telemetry
so i'm going to show you examples of how
to do custom metric instrumentation both
in
open census which is a project that's
been around for a little bit longer
and also open telemetry which is in your
project
so let's take a look at a code example
of how to use
the open census metric instrumentation
library in node.js
to define a custom metric right
there are basically a couple steps that
you have to do
first you define a measure and then you
define a view
right if you think about kind of back to
going to the monitoring api
right the view is going to create the
metric descriptor the measure is going
to create the specific time series
and then you're going to actually write
values against those
one thing you should notice is here at
the bottom when i'm
creating a latency metric because i want
to have a latency sli
i actually have to explicitly specify
the buckets of my histogram
right open sensors does not allow me to
do that automatically now it's very
explicit about the fact that this is
something that i'm required to do as i
write my instrumentation
so you should be very cautious when
you're um you could
be tracking latency within your
application using opencensus you may
want to use this kind of instagram
when you define the buckets you need to
define the buckets in a way that will
actually allow you to create
meaningful slos right your buckets have
to be precise enough to capture
the you know the values that are
basically within slo
versus those values that are outside of
your xlr
as the next step once i've got the
metric i can then go and create
my service level objective right so this
is an example of an api
call that i would use to specify the
service level objective
you can see that i'm using a request
based slo and i'm basically saying i
want to count the
the requests within a specific time
interval
whose response time threshold is lower
than my value
um all across total requests and then i
just put a goal on that slo which is
what percentage of requests have to
follow within that particular time value
right uh when i look in cloud monitoring
right there's my metric and then i can
create
a slo with that right so kind of
summarizing
open census right you have to uh
basically
create two different type two different
primitives you have to create a measure
to define the type of the metric and you
have to create the view to define how
that metric is going to be aggregated
and then specifically for latency slis
you need to be careful about how you
define your histogram bucket
to make sure that they're precise enough
to capture the thresholds that you're
then going to be defining in yours
let's now take a look uh look at an uh
an example of how you do this with open
telemetry which is
you know the new project right if we
take a look at the code
we'll see that defining the the metric
is is quite a bit simple
right i don't have to go through the
process of creating a
viewer and a measure i just simply
create create the metric
uh and there i am right all i have to do
is
then essentially issue a call to write
the values
so defining my metrics using open
telemetry is quite a bit easier
which is obviously great you know the
big trade-off kind of the thing that's
actually lacking in open telemetry today
is this idea of an exporter so in open
census there's a essentially a native
exporter that essentially allows me to
write metrics
directly to the cloud monitoring backend
open telemetry does not yet have an
exporter
for cloud monitoring for metrics and so
i have to essentially use
a intermediary to get my metrics from my
application
into the cloud monitoring backend and in
this example i'm actually using the
prometheus exporter
which also will then require me to set
up the prometheus integration with cloud
monitor
but once i've done that i can then go
ahead and define my
uh my slo in the same way that i did
when i used open senses and you can see
the metric here actually has the
external dot google apis.com
prometheus prefix right because because
i'm using the prometheus exporter
the metrics actually make it into the
back end as
uh you know as prometheus metrics right
so looking at the differences between
open sensors and open telemetry
you know open telemetry does make it
easier to declare the metrics so the
application side instrumentation is
i think quite a bit easier to use the
trade-off there is the
the ingestion instrumentation is a
little bit more complex because you
actually need to have an additional
layer of infrastructure
to do the ingestion and you have to use
prometheus as that intermediary
intermediary
whereas open census allowed you to just
write those metrics directly
um so looking at the combination of open
sentences and open telemetry right your
big advantage
here is that uh you know you write the
metrics directly
and also if you want to get started with
distributed tracing
you can actually use the same library to
do both tracing and metrics both in the
case of open sentence and open telemetry
you know the trade-offs are going to be
right what language is your application
written in does it
have support for does open telemetry or
open senses for
your application language and you know
specifically in the case of open
telemetry you know how you're going to
get the metrics into the back end right
are you
going to be willing to uh manage the
prometheus infrastructure
to get that ingestion to happen which
obviously brings us to our last option
which is while we can
not use application level
instrumentation libraries we just use
prometheus
directly right so prometheus is kind of
the de facto standard for monitoring in
the open source ecosystem it's certainly
been something that folks have been
using on
kubernetes for uh quite a while there's
lots of immigrations that are available
you know the big trader for prometheus
is there's like essentially two
additional pieces of infrastructure that
you actually have to maintain in order
for this to happen one is you need the
prometheus server itself
so in the case of applications running
in gke you need to have the prometheus
server deployed in the same cluster
where your application is
and then the second thing you need to do
is you need to actually patch that
server with what's called the prometheus
cloud monitoring sidecar the sidecars
was going to take the metrics from
prometheus
and import them into cloud monitoring so
for kind of a specific example of how
this would actually work right let's
take a look at the code first
you can see that declaring metrics in
prometheus is you know just
essentially just as easy as it was on
open telemetry right this is a very
mature library it's been around for a
long time
there's lots of examples of how to do
this in this in my example specifically
for latency sli
i again have to manually or
explicitly manage my histogram buckets
and again i just have to make sure that
i'm setting them up in a sufficiently
precise way such that i can then define
slos using those metrics right and
here's an example of how i would write
an slo
using uh prometheus metrics right so
kind of summarizing that right
uh you can use request based slis using
prometheus metrics
pretty straightforward uh the big
tradeoff there
is this need to maintain additional
infrastructure and
sidecar and specifically to measure
latency using prometheus you do need to
be very precise about how you define the
buckets to make sure that you have
the buckets are essentially precise
enough to capture those requests that
are
yeah within slo and those requests are
out of slo
at a bare minimum so that's a
those are all the options that we've
kind of gone through as to how you might
go about
instrumenting your own applications
running in google cloud
to expose additional metrics that you
can use for service level indicators
and then for service level objectives to
summarize everything we've talked about
today
right just like mike said at the
beginning there's a lot of value that
you can get
just by starting with the out of the box
metrics load balancer metrics
and things like that to define slis if
you need to create your own
you know evaluate your options right
there's going to be tradeoffs with each
one so
kind of figure out what makes sense for
you but ultimately it's really important
that you
focus on user happiness and your
monitoring do you really understand you
know who are our users
how do they use our services how do our
services
enable them to meet their goals so that
you can really measure
and manage reliability by focusing on
the end user
right here's what you get when you do
this you get slo dashboards and cloud
monitoring that looks like this
right you get all the slos in a single
place you get any alerts that are
associated with them
uh and as we've covered over the last
few minutes this sls can be created on
metrics that are ingested automatically
or all the cost
custom metrics that we've just talked
about you also get this in context
information about things like metrics
and logs and
underlying infrastructure so lots of
value that you
get by using this approach to monitoring
rather than just relying on
infrastructure metrics
so thank you so much for uh for watching
uh if this is a topic that you have
additional interest in here are some
other sessions in this track that you
may
want to tune in we really appreciate it
thank you again for watching
mike thank you so much really appreciate
you being here
and take care be safe thank you
you